i'm ellen tripler from american
university and my film dying green is
the story about one man's vision of how
your death can help conserve land i hope
you enjoy the clip
listen to my cicada tape
see up there
all right the burial today is for carol
williams did you figure what she's a
professor no i've got to i've got to ask
them but she was a professor in um
at the university of south carolina
but it's just three of her close friends
today
randy harold over in greenville from
palmetto funeral home did the cremation
billy and kimberly campbell
actually sought me out
and kimberly campbell had called she
recognized that as an alternative
provider we might be more inclined to
serve families in the way they wanted to
our business grows and continues to grow
as people are more educated on the
environment about the different options
they have
10 years ago folks would consider only
traditional burial with embalming but
for for me
as an alternative provider i do have
people asking
questions about how it affects the
environment
whenever we deliver cremated remains to
a family or to
the ramsey creek preserve these things
are removed
and recycled
with the medical waste company locally
there are
knee replacements
hip replacements